continuemos con nuestra demostración del
teorema de stocks y esta vez vamos a
enfocarnos en el otro lado del teorema
del lado izquierdo así que vamos a
intentar descubrir cuál es la integral
del ine a lo largo de esta frontera sé
que de hecho es la frontera de nuestra
superficie ese entonces lo que vamos a
tratar de descubrir es ahora quién es la
integral de f punto de r a lo largo de
nuestra curva sé que es justo esta
frontera ok entonces queremos nos
gustaría mucho que esto fuera igual a
esta expresión de acá arriba pero bueno
vamos a borrarlo por ahorita sólo hay
que recordar a donde nos gustaría llegar
ok entonces lo que vamos a hacer primero
es fijarnos en esta trayectoria que
define digamos a la región r
ok está esta curva digamos ajá que vamos
a recorrer para definir qué es la que
bordea la frontera de nuestra de nuestra
región
r digamos que ésta
curva vamos a llamar c 1 ok entonces
tienes c1 c1 vamos a poder parametrizar
la de la siguiente forma vamos a tener
hace uno que tiene esencialmente como es
es tiene dos parámetros xy pues vamos a
parametrizar lo con con digamos el
parámetro t entonces nuestra coordenada
x en realidad vamos a entenderla como
una función de nuestro parámetro te
vamos a este simbólico de tres líneas
significa que vamos a entenderlo de esta
forma y también vamos a entender hay
como una función que también depende de
nuestro parámetro t ok y simplemente
vamos a decir que te está entre dos
valores ahí ve sólo que digamos si aquí
empezamos en nada vamos a recorrer a
medida que te aumenta aunque y vamos a
recorrerlo hasta regresar al punto
inicial ok entonces x que valen lo mismo
al evaluarlos en a que al evaluarlos en
be ok entonces con esto dicho vamos a
hacer también uno
repaso vamos a hacer un repaso tomando
un campo vectorial cualquiera digamos g
ok este es un campo vectorial así que
está hecho de dos funciones dos
funciones digamos a este campo vectorial
está en el plano entonces este campo
vectorial está hecho de dos funciones
digamos m que depende de x y en nuestra
primera coordenada y hay que sumarle una
función n que depende también de xy de y
en nuestra segunda coordenada entonces
con esto dicho vamos a ver quién es
nuestra nuestra derivada de r ok quienes
se reparen bueno déjenme déjenme primero
decir que es lo que vamos a hacer con
esto porque r es digamos la la
parametrización que vamos a dar de
nuestra curva c 1 ok entonces
br es igual a de x por i + d y por j ok
estamos hablando en términos
diferenciales entonces lo que vamos a
querer hacer es calcular la integral la
integral a lo largo de nuestra curva c1
ok vamos solo esto es acuerdense sólo es
un repaso vamos a ver quién es la
integral de g y de hecho como se 1 es
una curva cerrada a mí me gusta poner lo
digamos con este simbólico como justo de
curva cerrada entonces vamos a hacer la
integral de línea sobre esta curva
cerrada deje punto de r ok de r donde de
r pues es justamente la diferencial
desde la de la curva parametrizar hace 1
entonces esto simplemente será igual
a la integral a lo largo de c1 c1 y como
es otra vez una curva cerrada le ponemos
esto de m.de x ok punto de x +
en el punto de aquí ya estamos pensando
en multiplicaciones es decir aquí era un
producto en un producto punto entre dos
vectores que es un vector es un campo
escalar que multiplica de r que también
es un vector digamos diferencial
entonces cuando multiplicamos coordenada
coordenada tenemos m por de x + n por d
pero aquí estamos multiplicando
números reales entonces quién es esto
esto esencialmente es la integral la
integral de hecho déjenme ponerlo así
porque la de x
déjenme ponerlo como por aquí la de x lo
podemos ver como la derivada de x
respecto del tiempo por la diferencial
del tiempo verdad es más o menos podemos
decir que estas dos cosas se cancelan y
que de ella es la derivada de ye
respecto de t por la diferencial del
tiempo entonces cuando nosotros
expresamos esto mismo acá abajo lo que
nos va a permitir
pasarnos al lado de los parámetros nos
lleva al dominio de los parámetros
entonces aquí vamos a poder escribir m
que multiplica
déjenme ponerlo de esta forma digamos
con estos colores de x a la derivada de
x respecto de t
vamos a ponerlo así dt más
+ n que multiplica a la derivada de y
respecto de t
dt ok entonces con esto he hecho de esta
forma ya estamos en el dominio de los
parámetros donde se mueve el parámetro t
pues entre a y b y esto ya es una
integral sencillísima de lo que ya hemos
visto mucho en techo en vídeos mucho más
anteriores verdad así que esto sólo es
un repasito breve
que nos va a servir para hacernos más
intuitivo el problema entonces vamos
ahora realmente con la parametrización
de la curva sé que es esta que de final
o que que es la frontera de nuestra
superficie ese entonces esta curva en
realidad es es como la imagen de esta
que está acá abajo al aplicarle la
función verdad sus coordenadas x y que
son las mismas sólo que vamos a elevarla
digamos con la función zeta verdad esta
función zeta aquí habíamos definido
nuestra función zeta de xy entonces al
aplicar zeta de xy ya a nuestra curva
no es como obtenemos la curva se
entonces dicho esto nuestra curva se
nuestra curva se esencialmente está
parametrizar de la siguiente forma vamos
a parametrizar lo digamos de forma
vectorial tenemos una función vectorial
o de posición r dt que en su primera
coordenada dijimos que iba a ser x
verdad x dt más en su segunda coordenada
será 7 esto es en la segunda coordenada
y en la tercera coordenada dijimos que
vamos a elevar esta curva por la función
zeta entonces va a ser z evaluada en x
que depende de t coma ya que depende de
t correcto esto en el en la dirección
del vector unitario acá y nuevamente
estamos suponiendo que el parámetro t se
mueve entre a y b así que ahí tenemos la
parametrización y ahora podemos empezar
a pensar en la integral de línea de f
punto de r a lo largo de esta
trayectoria c
ok así que ya hemos ya hemos dado con la
ayuda de c-1 está esta curva que rodea a
la región r una parametrización de c
aquí los voy a dejar y nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo